the polls in the critical state of
michigan are showing a very tight
contest as
republican optimism appears to be
growing by the day
while democrats seem to be increasingly
nervous president obama now
will be headed with joe biden on the
campaign trail to michigan on saturday
meanwhile republican senate candidate
john james he is running a very close
neck and neck race with the democratic
incumbent gary peters
in the state here with moore is former
u.s ambassador to the un former governor
of south carolina nikki haley
and michigan senate candidate john james
i've always said mr james that i thought
you're a rock star
and i believe this is the year how close
is it
what do you see for your race what's
happening on the ground in michigan for
you and the president
well i'm not a star i'm just a servant i
do everything i can to bring glory to
god in everything i do
and put jesus uh teachings to uh
of love and to action everything we're
doing and people in the state of
michigan that answer makes you a star
you could have taken all the credit and
you didn't good for you
well i appreciate that but it's about
what i can do for the people of state of
michigan who've been so disappointed
by an ineffective career politician in
gary peters who doesn't show up for work
and continues to vote partisan party
line please go to john james for senate
dot com to learn more about how i can
better serve my state
and the nation this could be the 51st
seat to protect our constitutional
republic and i need your help
um you know nikki one of the things that
scares me is that
the power grab democrats are saying they
will be involved in
i'm not sure if that if people
fully understand court packing i'm not
sure if they
really understand you know four new
democratic senators
or the impact of amnesty on the on
politics for the future
you know sean i mean there's a lot at
stake i mean whether it's
you know a conservative or court versus
court packing whether it's law and order
versus riots and defunding the police as
we see in philadelphia
you know whether it's education given in
the hands of parents versus education by
bureaucrats whether it's foreign policy
that's strong
or it's foreign policy where you buy
friends with foreign aid or whether it's
free enterprise versus
socialism there's a lot at stake but let
me tell you we are campaigning here in
michigan
everybody's excited everybody's talking
about john james
this is going to be a fun election here
in michigan because they get it
they get his energy they get new ideas
they get the fact that this is a guy
who's
signed the front of a paycheck not the
back of a paycheck
and he's going to make a difference in
washington and so
i think he's a rock star i think
everybody that sees him
he's a rock knows he's a rock star and
i'm excited about what he's going to do
he is going to
rock chuck schumer's world yeah and by
the way you just promise me you can't go
bend sass on me when you get there okay
because
uh he went a little bit nuts um
what do you see as the difference the
biggest issues
mr james in terms of you know what these
what these two campaigns for president
are about
well the biggest issues is uh who's for
the people of the state of michigan who
is for
our constitutional rights and in our in
our moral values
uh right now i'd ask america who do you
trust with your first amendment rights
who do you trust
with your second amendment rights who do
you trust with your freedom i've always
been taught that when your opponents
tell you that they're going to do
something you better believe them
when they tell you that they are going
to shut down oil
uh and and energy independence you
better believe them when they tell you
they're going to bring forward the green
new deal that would decimate the
automotive industry you better believe
them
when they tell you that they're going to
abolish the electoral college that would
shut out midwestern states from having a
voice in the presidential election
you better believe them and my opponent
was just endorsed by aoc because he's
going to be less than a speed bump
on the leftist roller coaster over to
the uh to the left extreme
go to john jenks for senate dot com i
need your help we need to make sure that
we have the truth
and that we maintain our republican
majority in the united states senate to
protect our constitution
well let me tell you this is absolutely
a winnable race
and president trump won by 10 700 votes
in 2016.
important everyone go vote